I saw an interesting documentary on the
BBC the other day called the truth about
slim people and the idea of this program
was that it followed people who are very
slim
despite not following any kind of
training regime or diet these are people
who just seem to be inherently slim
there are many different reasons so you
might struggle to lose weight or that
you might find it easier to lose weight
in fact I did a whole video on it but
what this documentary honed in on was
the fact that these people these slim
people they had far more active
lifestyles they weren't necessarily
going to the gym and things but it's
just in between workouts in between
everything else they were just more
active they might Bob their leg they
might dance around the kitchen they
might walk a little bit further so it's
actually the time between training that
counts more at least according to this
program when it comes to losing weight
this concurs with a theory called
healthy homeostasis which basically says
that we maintain a certain weight by
increasing or decreasing our activity on
the down low as we increase and decrease
our calories so if you eat a little bit
more one day then you might be slightly
more active you might bound up the
stairs with a spring in your step or you
might toss and turn a bit more up night
you might think faster you might speak
faster you might just Bob your leg a bit
more and of course your metabolism might
ramp up on the other hand if you don't
get quite as many calories that day then
you're gonna be slightly slow it might
be a bit tire there in the evening it
might move a little bit less this of
course makes it difficult to lose weight
because when you reduce your calories
you're also reducing your activity and
thereby still maintaining a kind of
status quo use a fitness tracker and you
might be led to believe that the workout
you just did was fantastic of putting a
huge dent in your number of calories
burned you might have burned say 200
calories
during a weightlifting session that's a
fair average however what you might have
forgotten and what the fitness tracker
and the glicks to tell you is that you
would have already burned 50 to 60
calories during that hour anyways just
from blinking breathing and being alive
so actually you've only burns about 150
calories
and suddenly this is only about the
equivalent of a four finger KitKat so
it's not gonna make a huge difference
again it's that activity during the day
that's actually more important than this
short bursts of intense activity and
this makes sense from an evolutionary
perspective as well we wouldn't of done
workouts in the wild
we'd have been constantly active we'd
have been either lying down recovering
or would have been hunting gathering
foraging fighting and there are tons of
health benefits to being active
throughout day as well one fairly well
publicized study concluded that for
every hour you spend sitting in front of
the TV you reduce your lifespan by 22
minutes now I don't know how much stock
to put in that but certainly a bit of a
wake-up call and there might be some
element of truth in it not only that but
regular activity throughout the day can
boost your mood helped me cope with
stress boost creativity executive
function so what's the solution well one
answer is incidental exercise this is
all the exercise that you do throughout
the day not as a training regime but as
part of your daily life that might mean
taking the stairs instead of the
elevator it might mean getting off your
bus or stop early so that you can walk
that distance it might mean choosing to
carry your shopping as a basket instead
of pushing your trolley around all these
things are helping you to burn a few
more calories to use your muscles a bit
more to get the blood flowing when you
wouldn't necessarily have to it's about
making healthy choices throughout the
day when it comes to your levels of
activity so take a look at your current
routine and ask yourself how much are
you actually moving if you drive to work
sit in an office all day come home ass
in front of the TV then there's probably
room for improvement and if you're not
losing weight by going to the gym for
half an hour three times a week then
maybe that's something you could look at
so now you can take a look at your
routine and you can find convenient and
practical ways to inject a little bit
more activity back into it so that
you're increasing your general amount of
exercise throughout the day or why not
set yourself some little goals like
trying to do 10 push-ups once every hour
and you'll be surprised at how much more
energetic you feel how much less stiff
how much less lethargic it feels like
you're taking this
bunch of time out of your day when you
really don't have time but actually
you'll get that time back several fold
but to take this to the next level we
can also do something called incidental
training I looked this up on Google and
it's not a thing I assumed it was so I
guess maybe I coined that term but who
knows basically the idea here is to
introduce micro workouts or even shorter
than micro workout so that might mean
that if you've just got 10 minutes
whilst you're working you can take a
short break do some curls and then get
back to work then maybe later on you
might take a short break and do some
chin-ups or you might take a short break
and do some squats we could even take a
very short 5-minute run around the block
before lunch or of course might mean
that you turn everyday activities into
workout so he might be curling your
shopping bag we might do calf raises on
a curve whilst you're waiting for your
bus maybe you're gonna do an isometric
hold trying to curl a railing whilst
you're waiting for your bus so now
you're thinking does this really work
can you really get benefits from such
short workouts and is it not gonna lead
to overtraining an answer to all those
questions depends on your goals and the
way you strategically introduce this
into your regime so yes you can
encourage growth in just 10 minutes
Tim Ferriss often refers to workouts
designed to be highly efficient for
stimulating hypertrophy as Emmy Dee's
minimal effective doses so you don't
need to do a 1-hour bicep session to get
some benefit from a biceps workout
especially if you're practiced if you
know how to get a burn for using
intensity techniques say a big drop set
you could quite quickly and easily get
your biceps pumped and burning and
whilst it wouldn't be as good as a whole
bicep day obviously it'll be better than
nothing that however would get you
sweaty it's not terribly convenient and
it could lead to overtraining rightly
more effective would be to do very heavy
single repetitions on compound lifts
like squats or deadlifts because you're
doing low rep high weights you actually
don't need to put that much time in if
you had a squat rack in your house or if
you had a barbell outside you can very
quickly do some deadlift or some squats
and you get all the same benefits in
just 10 minutes you might want to do a
quick warm-up of course but again
there's a chance of burning out your
central nervous system there's a chance
of injury and like I say you can get
sweaty it's not terribly convenient so
again this isn't something that you're
gonna want to do often or a lot of as
for those very short bursts of cardio
there are some studies to show that very
short and sporadic
frequent bursts of cardio can improve
your fitness obviously not as much as
long runs but again better than nothing
and they have also been shown to improve
a dierence meaning you're more likely to
stick to it but again you're going to be
running in your work clothes you're
gonna have to get changed gonna be
sweating when you come home a lot of
this is about doing what you can do
conveniently to fit it into your day
otherwise you might as well do a full
workout so the best way to use these
kinds of exercises is strategically
maybe to top up the workout that wasn't
as long as it should have been if you
don't have much time as a feeder workout
just to pump some blood to the muscles
the next day in order to encourage
growth and recovery or of course if you
just really can't fit in a full workout
and this is the only way you're gonna
get that training I've been using little
sporadic workouts like this as one of
the ways to cope with the added demands
and low energy that comes from being a
parent much more effective though would
be to choose better suited forms of
exercise so for instance overcoming
isometrics squeezing a grip trainer or
pushing against something or doing a
bull worker pushing or pulling against
an immovable force I've talked about it
a lot this helps to really build the
neural connections to help you recruit
more muscle fiber and because there's no
eccentric portion there's no lengthening
of the muscle your file it's likely to
cause inflammation burn you're less
likely to impair your workout the next
day grip training in particular is hard
on the central nervous system you need
to ease it in gently but as you do this
and as you adapt eventually you can
introduce this around your other
workouts and be just fine the other good
thing about overcoming isometrics of
course is that they don't tend to make
you very sweaty they don't need much
equipment to they're perfect you can
just do the grip trainer what's the
kettle's boiling or you can try to a
bull worker just wash your computer's
booting up likewise you could use some
concentric only exercises that I talked
about recently in my video on work
capacity so things like tire flipping
and again that shouldn't fatigue you as
much the next day likewise if you're
using very light weights so for instance
if you're doing a deadlift with a very
light weight or if you're doing pull-ups
just using bodyweight then you can
practice what's called greasing and
groove this is talked about by Pavel Sat
suelen hopefully I've said that name
correctly
basically he suggests that if you repeat
movements over and over again you're
practicing strength strength is a skill
and therefore you can improve your
technique you can improve your muscle
fiber recruitment
you can get stronger you can get more
efficient at performing those movements
essentially what's happening in the
brain is that you're encouraging long
term potentiation you're thickening the
neural pathways through myelination to
help yourself to more efficiently move
through that movement
thereby apply of strength in a more
correct manner thereby be able to lift
more or perform more repetitions so keep
some parallettes in your office and try
and do the planche every now and then
it's not going to really tax your system
at all but the practice is going to make
you stronger it's going to help to
balance better and it's just a great way
to get the blood flowing and very common
one is just to keep a pull-up bar on
your doorframe and every time you walk
through you have to do some chin-ups or
some pull-ups this is a great way to get
better at pull-ups to be able to do more
pull-ups and it's a really good way to
get the blood pumping and finally
remember that it's not just strength
that you need to Train if you watch this
video then you might well be interested
in training your brain you might be well
interested in training flexibility or
balance on jump height and these are all
things that you can do throughout your
day if you take a look at your routine
and look at where you can fit them in so
for instance you can do some stretching
in the shower
why stand on two feet when you could be
balancing on one why walk through the
gate when you could jump over it why
right with your dominant hand when you
could write with your left hand in order
to Train ambidexterity why walk
somewhere when you could jog why jog
when you could jog backwards into train
completely different muscles you'll get
some weird looks but who cares in other
words everything can be training and in
terms of brain training why not practice
mindful ironing this is basically the
idea that if you focus 100% on a mundane
tasks such as ironing it could become a
form of meditation
so yeah anything can be training and
there's a lot of benefit to introducing
more training throughout your day so I
found this video useful interesting guys
if you did then please leave like please
check around comment down below and let
me know if the inventive ways that you
train throughout your day if you indeed
have any I've got tons more videos on
the way sorry if there's any that you're
particularly looking forward to taking
awhile I just want to do them right and
I'm putting a lot more effort and time
into the video editing and things so
that's why they're taking longer I'm
trying to introduce these shorter quick
tips as well as a kind of trade-off but
yeah I'm gonna get to everything as
quickly as I can and yeah I have a huge
list of really cool stuff that I'm
getting to so thanks for being patient
and sticking with me on a massive thanks
to my patrons over at patreon it's
thanks to you guys I've been able to
increase the quality of these videos
with things like this stock footage and
the better editing I invested
in vital elements for instance and yeah
hopefully it's really paying off so I'm
really grateful to you guys and if you
want to get involved then there's a link
in the description down below thanks a
ton for watching guys and I'll see you
next time bye for now